Speaker 1: , I also invite you to
join the discussion on our sub Reddit.
I'm selling you nothing other than a good
time. It's free. You can find it at David
Pakman dotcom slash Reddit. A couple of posts
I spotted this morning that I want to address
one user posted. Does anyone else feel like the
left needs to reclaim the American flag? The right
waves the flag and other American symbols all day
long, and most left wing people don't even own a
flag. I feel like it makes it easy for them to
paint us as unpatriotic. What are your thoughts?
You know, I tend to disagree with this. To me,
the flag waving is very tacky and rather than
reclaiming the flag, I would rather see the left
reclaim what patriotism is and make it something
other than waving a flag. And what
I mean by that is I've talked before
about a sort of more sensible, logical type
of patriotism. The philosopher Alain de Botton
has written about this as well, which is
patriotism is, hey, look at these amazingly
well-designed cities. We have look at how much
we've been able to achieve in terms of dealing
with pollution and our carbon footprint. How great
should we feel about developing alternative energy
and making sure people have health care? Those
are the things that should start to be reclaimed
as patriotic rather than the flag waving. To
me, the flag waving is just kind of tacky.
Let's reclaim patriotism. You know, in Argentina,
my my birth country, people who visit the US from
Argentina often mentioned to me, what's with the
flags like? Yea, I got here, I assumed it was Flag
Day because I just drive by houses and people
have flags on vehicles in some states. What's
going on with flags in Argentina and in many
other countries there is a day where you display
the flag and then it's sort of like we live normal
lives. We're not constantly fetishizing the flag,
maybe going more in the direction where the flag
is less a symbol of patriotism rather than trying
to reclaim the flag. That's my instinct. But
I'm I'm open to having a different perspective
presented to me on the left and the flag. Another
post asks, what the hell is happening in August?
Something is clearly happening in August. There's
a New York Times story saying Trump is telling
people he'll be reinstated by August. I just heard
Mike Lyndell talk about August. Does anyone here
monitor Magga groups? Is there a plan yet? What
is Magga think is happening in August? I'd bet a
thousand dollars. Right now. There's another coup
attempt in the works. Does anyone have a concept
of what that might look like? Well, tomorrow I'm
actually going to talk about Michael. And Dell
is now shifting from saying Trump will be
reinstated in August to it could be September.
But I share the concern that there could be
violence when, of course, Trump doesn't get
reinstated whenever it is. We've talked about
it last week and previously. And I also have
a fear that we may be heading towards some kind
of violence when, of course, Trump's not going
to be back in office this year. And it remains
to be seen if and when that will take place.
But that's what's going on, that Trump and others
have started floating August as when Trump will be
back. He obviously won't. And there's no telling
how that's going to trigger some of his followers.
Join the discussion on the sub. Read it
at David Pakman. Dotcom slash. Read it.